is the economic crisis in greece finally
over
in one of the country's most important
industrial areas aspergos we set out in
search of an answer
many of the factories like this concrete
plant seem to be abandoned
company manager constantinos campolis
wants to hold on to his firm even though
it's been losing money for years now
hardly anyone builds any more in greece
and it's been that way for a while
but the survival of his company depends
on the domestic construction trade
a huge problem right now is that no one
pays their bills on time
500 meters away there's a different
surprising grease spiridon de lendas
invested in new machines this year
they're for metalworking the company has
record-breaking sales thanks to new
customers abroad
exports are going to all over the world
even to australia
to tell the truth many companies have
been well positioned for some time
and are concentrating on exports
and they're moving into new markets
because they've improved their quality
that really contributes to success
and i believe it's the future
the company is taking on more than it
used to now they often even assemble the
products of their customers
they're also working on prototypes like
the service trolley for the italian
state railway
no one has lost their job and the
workers haven't had to take pay cuts
seven and ten of my friends are out of
work we've come to a point where we're
embarrassed to say we're working
the country is plagued by an
unemployment rate of nearly 30 percent
that alone is enough to nip optimism in
the bud
it's even worse for the young two out of
three young people have no job
like timolian sikiotis and michalas
francia dulacas
where they live on the outskirts of
athens nothing new has developed to
improve their outlook
last year they were still working as a
cab driver and a salesman
now they live with their parents and are
supported by them as well
unfortunately we're a cursed generation
there's simply no work for us
if there are jobs then the pay isn't
even enough to feed you
i know a 24 year old who earns about 250
euros in monthly take-home pay working
at a supermarket
i was at a company where they showed me
500 applications for just one job
it's hopeless
and they're still letting more and more
people go
at the same time more people are being
forced to work off the books and without
social security
even economic experts like savas rabolis
say they have little hope for their
country
there's no light at the end of the
tunnel the future is dark
look at these signs
these offices are for rent or sale
insurance companies or commercial
businesses are here
more and more are going broke
roboli says the wave of bankruptcies
will continue in 2014.
next year we don't think the contraction
will be as bad as the four percent we
had this year
but the economy will shrink by 1.5
percent in 2014.
unemployment will rise to 31
high taxes for private individuals and
companies remain a burden
he says that after seven years of crisis
2015 could be when things turn around if
experts continue to grow and shift the
economy's mood